welcome to this video MTG I am MTG okay
let's see what we got yeah what I could
claim what about the Pannone and played
this for ages at least here i'm not
getting completely killed by the by the
by the f4 lines that i don't know i mean
not that i know that very well but at
least i hear i feel i shouldn't lose
quickly so 97's once set up 96 the other
i'm going for the night a cig set up a
knight always comes here
hmm did I play this too early I don't
know he cannot easily go for a five sd5
is hanging so night see for now arguing
that be five is leading to issues with
Knight a5 at least I have fun have some
pressure on on d5 so that he cannot
easily easily am push a five I wonder
what about what about this actually
Bishop de force maybe maybe really all
managed form
sometimes in the Benoni this crazy stuff
is actually good ok so a thought queen
age form would be at least interesting
let's then he has to go h3 of course to
check in
it takes h3 h4 each week we have to
check king in the corner you can go back
to h4 for a draw funny that's funny ok
let's go there first and then work out
the details so I can play this here and
back don't know i mean that's some way
check let's start with that King h1 and
now anyway anyway to not probably not
let's do that threatening night f2
I'm not saying he must repeat or
anything but don't know I couldn't
retreat the night so this is probably
the way to go the FCC is ok with the
draw yeah I don't know if I can do
something better that's my problem night
f2s is probably completely useless or
not night f2 for Queen where r Queenie
to I guess or queen t 2
Queenie true but this this gives some
tactical chances at least can jump to d3
how weird is that come on let's let's
try that looks totally crazy Queenie 293
looks completely bonkers maybe I mean
queen f3 or something I have no debts
which I can take only one even that is
not clear I mean he can take on d6 and
it's a complete it stolen mayhem yeah
he's allowing that but it's really not
clear how bad it is for him aveiro I
mean yeah this is this is why you play
this this opening of the Benoni for
those crazy non-symmetrical positions
okay so look the eight of em I'm
allowing him to take yeah I have to move
it simply it's an exchange but what a
messy position and he definitely has a
good good porn center
I wonder Bishop f5 is this a move you
threatened special III I can go back
though i don't know i have to play it's
it's too little time to to do long
things
yeah white as compensation clearly but
not not not clear how much it is
definitely something we should page six
putting anything on this pawn anything
everything on this pawn
yeah this Hanks I know I know I know I
know that's not very nice if he gets it
time warning distress this bloody d6
pawn
rock two three at least
hmm still I still don't don't understand
it here maybe you should go to one if
this is working can take on g1 and f4
though there should be six route III
which shouldn't know him and not enough
Bishop g4 I'm going to take so night
takes or how to say I have to move okay
look here I'll check here but it's after
i've got a king g7 okay that could have
been a checkmate didn't even see this
this idea i think it's not on our twin
h6 matin almost no we didn't do that
Jack I cannot take on edge three what a
shame now I'm completely cracking down
now I do anything no and I did lose the
game I don't believe it a drug leave
Walton's on time come on I cannot
believe that that this is not good for
black come on it's a draw actually I was
really thought I'm finally finally
breaking through here yeah mmm Queenie
one and resins okay that was them that
was the win but what did he do wrong he
has to go night is seven in this
pollution Chang yeah I really thought I
mean the problem was I didn't even see
Queen a check when i move drooped III
jack
rook g 5 is minus 15 that's quite a lot
for this yeah I completely lost my nerve
iam so totally i didn't know i didn't
see anything him this is this is I mean
what else him he doesn't have a check
and I'm threatening this and now the
computer finds a force mate rub it in
rub it in yeah ok it was a it was a
completely crazy game from beginning to
end um yeah if he went he went with this
yeah it was clear that white has
compensation it's a completely messy
position now looked his 6cm was a
possibility Chang yeah I had this idea
but I never really saw a moment where I
could play it and here it looks nice him
if I can get this back his pawn
structure is destroyed by this is
winning an even stock 4-2 yeah of care
when i get d 6 I am winning he's got a
completely deteriorated pawn structure
bad King and so on yeah our very messy
game okay well thanks for watching